so in the second volume of Harry Potter
correct me if I have any of these
details wrong you rember there's that
snake the basilisk so this is Magic
Castle right you guys have no problem
without magic castles no problem
there's an orphan orphan he goes to the
Magic Castle to learn how to be more
than normal right the muggle he has a
muggle family we're not too happy with
the model family like as representatives
of normal people they they have some
blacks now of course the reason for that
is that well that's what teenagers often
feel about their parents right they feel
Jesus these couldn't really be my
parents I must have some other parents
who are like together
those are like magical parents right
parents that live in the sky and of
course Harry Potter has earthly parents
that's the muggles and Dursley I think
is the kid he's a 1 he's a wonderful
piece of work and you know ill-formed a
spoiled ill-formed selfish very far from
the ideal
he's a foil for Harry and of course he's
appreciated and doted on and Harry is
actually punished for his virtues that's
a classic story right to be punished for
your virtues I mean if you look at the
story the central story in Christianity
the central story and Christianity is
about someone who is precisely punished
in the worst possible way for the
highest possible virtues that's what it
makes it an archetypal story because
there isn't anything more unfair than
that and so it's a limit in a sense you
it can't be worse than that being
punished for being you know unworthy
it's like yeah yeah well at least makes
sense but to be punished because you
have your act together and you're a good
person that's real punishment and that's
what happens to Harry so luckily he
finds out that he's magical which is
quite convenient and off he goes to
Wizarding school and you know that's
actually like taking that's actually
like going and studying the humanities I
mean it was when they still were you
know because it's through the humanities
that you that you make contact with the
magic of your culture and that makes you
more than merely the child
your parents because you are more than
merely the child of your parents you're
the child of nature and you're the child
of culture and until you understand what
that means
understand that you have two sets of
parents like the divine hero always have
two sets of parents you you can't
construe yourself properly as an
individual you're not situated properly
in the world you don't know what your
responsibilities are you can't orient
your values properly and you will suffer
for that
because as far as I can tell because
life is so difficult you have to do
something that's truly worthwhile in
order to justify it and so well that's
what all these stories tell you that's
what the story of Jonah is telling you
it's like you know ethical duty to
straighten things up and if you don't do
it you're going to be sorry and that
stories echoed everywhere while now st.
George well let's go to Harry Potter
that's what we're talking about so he
goes off the Magic Castle
and learning to be a wizard and he's
kind of an interesting character a
because he's not really good and we find
out I think that's because doesn't have
a piece of Voldemort enum he's not what
happened yeah and that's what that means
is it to be good truly good you can't
just follow rules that's that's very
clear in the Harry Potter story and you
also have to be able to understand
malevolence and in order to understand
malevolence so that you can withstand it
you have to understand that part of you
that's malevolent because if you don't
you're naive and if you're naive you're
easy pickings and so that's a union idea
too and the Union idea is that part of
personality development is to understand
your shadow and the shadow is those
things about you that you do not want to
admit to and you can learn about your
shadow by reading history you know you
can read about Auschwitz you can read
about the concentration camps in Russia
and you can imagine
yourself as a guard instead of as a
heroic rescuer of unfortunate victims
which would be very very unlikely and
once you can imagine yourself as a guard
which is a terrifying thing to do then
you understand something about yourself
and I actually think and I think this is
also from student studying young that
you cannot have proper respect for
yourself until you know that you're a
monster because you won't act carefully
enough you know if you think well I'm a
nice person I'd never do anyone any harm
it's like you're no saint you can be
sure of that and the harm that you do
people can come in many many ways
and so if you regard yourself as
harmless inoffensive nice well why do
you have any reason to be careful you're
like a teddy bear sitting on a shelf
even if you throw it at someone no one's
going to get hurt but that isn't what
you're like if you're a human being and
human beings are some vicious creatures
and their utility and knowing that
because it's also the case you know in
the Harry Potter series Harry could
stand up against full demurred and
understand them and speak his language
because he was infected by him to some
degree very very interesting idea
anyways in the second ten the reason I'm
telling you this and this is worth
thinking about like how long were each
of those books like 500 pages they're
long a and there was how many of them
seven and how many of them were sold I
mean how many of you read every Harry
Potter book right that's how many of you
read at least one okay how many you saw
the movies like you're all in a cult you
are I'm doing you really that's the
truth it's really the truth so in the
second volume there's this snake that
slip it around there the basilisk right
and it lives in the underground that's
chaos that's chaos and that's because
wherever you are you're on thin ice and
underneath
thin ice is chaos and here we are in
this unbelievably civilized environment
and everyone's getting along so
perfectly but you know we've got hot
lights with electricity the sewage
system is working no one's hungry it's
like you can be peaceful but if any of
that fell apart and it could easily fall
apart because it's a bloody miracle it
ever works at all then the chaos that's
just underneath the surface is going to
come up right now and it's useful to
know that because it makes you properly
grateful if you really understand it it
makes you properly grateful for the
bloody miracle that it is that you can
be here in peace
so anyways there's this snake that's
underneath the surface and it's you know
no joke that thing it's big and it's
ancient it's always been there and what
happens if you look at it it turns you
to stone right it paralyzes you well
that's the more that's the Gorgon that's
Medusa the woman with the head of snakes
and if you look at her it paralyzes you
what does that mean well you're walking
through the jungle and big snake appears
what do you do you freeze and no bloody
wonder because you're a prey animal and
that's what they do when they see things
that are going to eat them and so the
snake well lots of people still die from
snakebite and our ancestors were I mean
our ancestors like you know tens of
millions of years ago when they were
living in trees and worked very big they
made a nice snack for a snake and
there's a woman named Lynn Isbell who's
an anthropologist at UCLA who's
correlated the presence of carnivorous
snakes with the acuity of primate
visions and what she found was that the
more snakes around the better the
primates could see so and we're
particularly good at picking up patterns
like snake camouflage in the lower half
of our visual quadrant you know and
people generally don't like snakes you
can learn to handle them but no snake
spear appears to be innate to Nate in
chimpanzees and it tends to increase as
you age rather
and decreasing you can overcome it but
well my daughter had snakes and one day
her snake bitter it was a very big snake
and she hadn't paid attention to it for
a while so it nailed her and from then
on she had very difficult time grabbing
the snake it was like bitten once you
know shy permanently she also told me
years later she had nightmares about
snakes all the time when she had a snake
in her room it's like you know and I
think it was probably the smell so
anyways so Harry Potter decides he's
going to go after the basilisk right
he's going to go out there and face the
thing that he's most afraid of so he
does that wait out in the depth so it's
like Jonah going down into the depth and
he faces the basilisk and it bites them
and you know that's a that's right
because if you go down into the depth
you can get bitten like it's no joke and
this is a hero story but the thing about
the hero stories it's actually real the
thing that you're facing is actually
dangerous and even though facing it
voluntarily might be your best bet and
is likely your best bet because that's
the central story of humanity that
doesn't mean you're going to succeed
it's the real thing so anyways he gets
bitten right and he's going to die
now he's rescuing Ginny so that's the
st. George story if you go after a
dragon dragons like to capture virgins
god only knows why I think it's because
I think it's because one of the things
that male humans have done from the
beginning of time is chase the damn
predators away and I suspect that the
males from god only knows how long ago
who were particularly good at that were
rewarded with female attention and why
the hell not
so it's deeply rooted inside of us that
idea of facing the unknown and freeing
the woman so the idea there is that if
you it's a male idea in large part I can
talk about the central female myth and I
will as we proceed the idea is that if
you're the sort of person who can stand
up against the unknown and the
frightening then you're also likely if
you develop into that sort of person
then you're also likely to develop into
the sort of person that other people
will find attractive so you know and
that's why young believe that the inside
the shadow was the anima which is like a
female figure and so his idea was
something like you know if you look
watch movies there's always this beta
male guy if they're romantic movies and
he's a nice guy and he's the friend and
you know the woman tells him everything
but she doesn't like him a bit she likes
the guy who's like God an edge and and
who's capable of I would say mayhem but
at least of aggression you know that
doesn't mean she wants him to be
aggressive but what it does mean is that
she wants him to be able to be
aggressive that would be good and so
he's the romantic target and so he's the
person that's incorporated the shadow
and he's someone that is respectable and
perhaps useful and so well that's a very
old story
so let's let's think about this for a
minute I've already offered you a
proposition
and I think it's an important
proposition and I'm offering you this
proposition so that you can make sense
of art and literature and mythology and
religion and dance and all those strange
ritualistic things that human beings do
which seem central to us including
including not least the in eradicable
tendency of us to seek out stories of
heroes I should finish the Harry Potter
story so Harry Potter goes down there to
rescue Virginia you know it's that's not
her name what is it Jenny yeah but
there's a formal name for that it's a
variant of Virginia anyways which is a
very divergent so um and he gets bitten
Jen yes jenever that's it he gets bitten
and the bite is poison and so there is
dying which doesn't seem to be so good
and then what happens and again you guys
swallow this it's no problem
so what's his name the Dumbledore
character he's got a bird right so he's
the wise old man he's the ruler of the
castle he's the ruler of the Magic
Castle he's the Magic King you know he's
like God the Father as far as Harry
Potter is concerned and he has a bird
what kind of bird is it it's a Phoenix
right and one of the things that's very
strange about a Phoenix is that well
it's immortal but in a strange way you
know it lives and lives I think a
hundred years and it gets older and
older and then one day post it burst
into flames and turns into an egg and
then you get a new Phoenix so that's a
symbol of transformation it's a symbol
of transformation the bird is a spirit
or psyche and so here's what it means in
part you know you know how when you
learn a lesson in your life that that's
not very pleasant right it's not like
when you learn something important
it's the
best day of your life it's often the
importance of what you learn is often
proportionate to just how wretched it is
to learn it you know you learn things
the hard way you learn things by getting
hit because obviously if what you're
doing is working you get what you want
there's no learning in that and that's
happy it's when you're doing something
and you hit an obstacle and maybe you're
bloody well hit it hard and then you
know you recoil and then you down into
the depths you go and you have to sort
yourself out you realize that you're you
know this particular kind of idiot and
that you should probably fix that and
that's really annoying and difficult and
you know and maybe you're down in the
dumps and anxious for quite a while and
then you get it repaired more or less
and you know you put yourself back
together
that's the Phoenix poof into flames bang
egg new you and so you know that's the
ability to learn now human beings are
very strange creatures right because
we're very malleable compared to most
animals you know like grizzly bears now
and grizzly bears a thousand years ago
it's like whatever they're the same
thing they do the same thing
there's no transformation about human
beings we have this massive brain and
you know it's a pain because it means
you have to take care of human children
until they're 40 and and that's a big
burden and so you know we pay a big
price for it it also makes childbirth
very difficult and and it's costly you
have to eat a lot because you have a big
brain because it uses up a lot of energy
and so you know you pay a price for it
but the advantage is your plastic you
can learn now the learning is a strange
thing because you can think of it as
just acquiring more information but you
could also think of it and this is more
accurate as finding out something that
you're doing wrong so that's sort of
built into you like a character a carrot
of your character a presumption of your
perception or a deep habit it's really
built into you to neural structure right
it's lit alive and you have to kill it
because it is working
properly and the pain that you go
through in part when you're suffering
because you did something stupid is it's
something like your your the neurology I
can never get this quite right it's the
pain of the death of that structure and
that could be a huge chunk of you you
know if you really have to go through a
massive revision it's like the person
that comes out the other end might
hardly be the same at all you know that
happens for example if you're trying to
combat alcoholism which is just you know
a wretched thing to do because well all
your friends are alcoholic and all your
family drinks too much the only thing
you know how to do when you're
socializing is to go to the bar and
drink too much you know you spend like
20 hours a week on it it's like it's not
just that you're addicted to the
substance it's like that's how you live
and so if you want to stop being an
alcoholic
not only do you have to stop drinking
alcohol but you have to stop seeing all
your drunk friends and maybe you've had
them for your whole life and you have to
have continual battles with your drunk
family and then you have to figure out
some to do with that 20 hours it's to
know like hanging around your neck like
an albatross and so you have to let that
whole part of your personality die and a
new part has to spring forth and that's
what the Phoenix is the Phoenix is the
capacity of the person to transform and
so when Harry gets bit by the snake that
freezes him he gets seriously injured
the Phoenix comes in Christ some tears
in his wound it prepares them bang he's
back to life and the strange thing is
that that's okay with all of the viewers
now why would that be
there's nothing about it that's rational
nothing right Magic Castle that's not
rational giant snake underneath it
that's a little more rational
turning you to stone going down there to
face it being rejuvenated by a Phoenix
it's like yeah yeah that's okay we can
we'll watch that clue well swallow like
we'll be completely engaged in it and
the reason for that is because it's a
myth it's about how people it's a meta
story about how to act about how to
conduct yourself in the world to face
the things that you're afraid of that
would otherwise paralyze you to let the
death of what is insufficient about you
occur and then to wait for the rebirth